in some of the world's coldest climates
teams of men and women don helmets eye
protection and warm clothes and head out
into the snowy terrain
to prepare for a battle against the
elements
and each other what is this form of
frigid weather fighting you ask
they call it yukigasan
yugi means snow gaston is war that's why
we are here now
established in 1988 as a way to
encourage tourism to japan in the winter
months
what was once a kid's game is now a
hardcore sport played in eight countries
they give us a present this is yogica
we are now here in kemir in arctic
circle because we are so not we have
snow and we can could play yugi question
every day or every weekend
kimmy yarvey is famous for holding the
european yukigasu tournament each year
it is here that three japanese players
have flown in for a scrimmage
against three local finnish yukigasan
players take your position
they have one snowball each hand and
referee visit they start and they try to
hit
yukigasan is a best of three rounds game
players who are hit by a single snowball
are out of the round
to win players must either steal the
flag from the opposing team or eliminate
all their players with snowballs
yukikazen is very tactic play you don't
have to be strong you must be small
and very quickly and you must have a
very good hand
teams play with regulation approved
snowballs made by machines
the perfect playing condition is just
below freezing
so the snowballs have enough moisture to
hold their form
they are quite heavy but not too heavy
so they can't be very hot they must be
broken when they hit
the sport is not without its hazards
the most important
is the helmet
if we hit in the head it doesn't hurt
the finished team might have won this
game
but win or lose the battlefields of
yukigasu have the power to unite not
divide
yugi question is now in my heart i love
yuki kasi so i like to spread this yugi
because i want that kids and adults
they play and say that this is fun and
people like it
[Music]
you